nos últimos dias mês na verdade fiquei
tentando preparar alguma coisa pra falar
com um roteirinho seguir os 18 minutos
implacáveis do ted
mas toda vez que eu ia preparar alguma
coisa ficava mais confuso e mais tenso e
mais é inseguro sobre o que tudo que a
gente fez no ano passado significou
então eu acho que o melhor que eu posso
fazer é encarar o desafio meio como
mídia ninja mesmo seja ao vivo é lidar
com o fluxo que está acontecendo não só
na minha cabeça mas na narrativa da
própria mídia ninja que leva esse nome
na sua sigla né
mas também não sei como vou começar que
é que é sobre eu por 11 anos eu fui um
jornalista numa mídia mais ou menos
convencional
trabalhei na revista trip por 11 anos a
fui repórter estagiário e até 2011
eu fui diretor de redação eu é assumir a
direção no começo de 2011
e nesses 11 anos eu perdi a conta de
quantas vezes eu fiz entrevistas de
quantas pessoas eu tive que questionar
né
e num ano passado cerca de nove meses
pra cá eu perdi a conta de quantas
entrevistas eu tive que dar
e essa inversão de papel tem uma coisa
muito esquisita que foi a única pergunta
que quase todo jornalista me fazia e era
tipo a primeira ou segunda assim o que
você faz é jornalismo e não só pra mim é
estranho porque eu sou um jornalista mas
como nunca me fizeram essa pergunta
antes e eu tenho muitas respostas como
me perguntava o que você faz é
jornalismo é foram várias maneiras de
falar assim é
mas toda vez eu tinha que pensar um
pouco sobre isso ea resposta que eu acho
que eu nunca dei na verdade eu fiquei
elaborando ela sozinho não é uma
resposta é uma pergunta que eu gostaria
de fazer na verdade que é o que é
jornalismo então se o que a gente estava
fazendo não é ou pelo menos a essa
dúvida se o que a gente fez o fazia ou
faz até hoje é ou não é jornalismo e eu
fiquei interessado porque é uma pergunta
que eu nunca vi responde de maneira
satisfatória e eu nunca me fiz essa
pergunta enquanto eu era assim um
jornalista enquanto ganhava grana como
jornalista trabalhando numa revista e eu
percebi no fundo hoje que nos últimos
três anos que eu vou falar um pouco
sobre esses últimos anos o meu trabalho
sem o perceber foi mais ou menos
descobrir o que é jornalismo na idade da
informação no mundo hiperconectado ou
seja o que é você sou um profissional de
é lapidar informação e difundir
informação e checar a informação
na idade da informação numa sociedade
hiperconectada o que é você ser um
profissional da comunicação social
na era em que a imprensa perdeu o
monopólio da comunicação social em que a
mídia hoje é um termo em aberto ou seja
todo mundo é um comunicador público todo
mundo produz e difunde informação o que
diferencia o jornalismo então o mais
interessante foi responder essa pergunta
na prática e não na teoria e aí eu me
lembro é que acho que todo mundo que
ajudou a fazer a mídia ninja e não foram
poucas pessoas têm algum episódio pra
falar a minha história começou assim
acho que esse dia foi o dia que eu me
sentir que eu comecei nesse caminho é de
rede de tentar ser um jornalista
conectado com uma nova lógica o meu vai
fazer três anos no sábado agora
precisamente na marcha da maconha de
pra quem não se lembra foi um mês muito
interessante que eu acho que muito pouco
recordado a partir de junho
principalmente porque foi um mês em são
paulo onde teve muitas marchas
e ela começou com uma muito interessante
que foi o churrascão da gente
diferenciada da gente lembra disso
mas pra mim foi um dia muito
significativo porque ele representou
pela primeira vez uma quebra na forma
tradicional como se convoca uma
manifestação bem sucedida no país foi
muito mais um meme muito bem colocado
muito mais uma ideia viral que apareceu
como uma piada mas se tornou de fato o
movimento que acabou gerando
conseqüências políticas mesmo que muito
curto mas representou essa quebra muito
grande eu tenho e tenho uma impressão na
semana seguinte ao da marcha da maconha
fui nela como um jornalista bem
analógico eu era e me sinto uma pessoa
particularmente analógica é meu primeiro
smartphone estava no meu bolso e eu eo
meu twitter se ela tinha 1 80 seguidores
tinham feito uns três pontos só o meu
facebook era absolutamente pessoal eu
fui como um diretor de redação que
queria cobrir a marcha eu ia produzir um
texto um mês depois fazer fotos em
entrevista a gente produziu uma
reportagem convencional
quando a marcha sai a polícia aparece em
condições muito semelhantes à de junho
do ano passado mandando bala bomba e gás
foi a primeira vez que eu fui agredido
pela polícia militar
foi a primeira vez que eu esperei
bastante gás lacrimogêneo e mas mais
importante do que isso foi a primeira
vez que a minha profissão é tomou um
caráter emocional imediato ao vivo
urgente a naquela hora já não me sentia
muito mais um repórter de revista
eu queria simplesmente me comunicar
urgentemente com as pessoas que estavam
em casa até porque no meu smartphone eu
já tava vendo que a mídia estava falando
que a polícia estava liberando o tráfego
na avenida paulista
eu não só queria questionar aquilo ali
mas não sabia do poder do ao vivo
daquela situação
traduzida que há um mês uma semana não
teria sentido eu comecei a usar o meu
twitter que era tudo o que eu tinha e
aqui a câmera do meu celular
na minha casa eu vejo que ele tinha sido
usado como referência para vários é para
vários é canal de comunicação é fazerem
as suas pautas e de menos de 100
seguidores estava com quase 3 mil
naquela hora eu senti uma coisa muito
intensa muito relevante no que estava
acontecendo e fiz um texto um relato em
primeira pessoa sobre aquela repressão
policial em questão de horas ele havia
sido visto por 70 mil pessoas em 24
horas 250 mil
em 11 anos de profissão nunca tinha é
repercutido tanto mas muito mais
importante do que isso é eu nunca havia
sentido uma função tão crucial no meu
trabalho e foi aí que ele se fundiu com
o ativismo de maneira deliberada
mesmo porque foi através da comunicação
social através dessa percepção de que o
mundo hiperconectado era uma fronteira
jornalística a ser explorada de maneira
decisiva a o fora do eixo me telefona e
é feita uma reportagem sobre eles ea
gente junto com os coletivos que
organizaram a marcha da maconha puxamos
uma marcha para a semana seguinte a não
era mais a função jornalística classe
caminha mas a minha função era promover
aquela marcha através de relatos de não
ficção o que acontece uma grande
coincidência online steam estava
chegando no país e ofereceu uma mochila
que era capaz de transmitir ao vivo era
capaz de fazer é capaz de fazer
streaming e prenda nunca havia feito
nunca havia visto um e faça não quer
fazer o streaming eu quero vamos lá
cederam esse equipamento que na época
era muito caro e muito o sofisticado e
eu entrei no ar
eu eo cod prado ficamos seis horas e
meia no ar cobrindo essa tal marcha
marcha da liberdade de todos os nomes e
nem chego em casa 90 mil pessoas haviam
visto foi não só muito chocante mas
ficou claro naquela hora que havia uma
fronteira muito muito clara se explorada
com o streaming com as possibilidades
tecnológicas que se abrem absurdamente e
com alguma coisa que significou nos
próximos anos a construção do que virou
a mídia ninja em 2013 que foi após tv ou
seja uma rede de strippers pessoas que
transmitem ao vivo no país inteiro e
esse é o ponto crucial que eu acho que
diferencia a criação da mídia ninja de
um veículo de comunicação convencional
ao ponto das pessoas nos perguntar isso
que a gente faz é ou não jornalismo há a
percepção foi não só têm uma fronteira
que tecnológica e mas existe uma
fronteira cultural o que significa na
minha cabeça idade da informação a era
da hiperconectividade é que o jornalismo
como como atividade em si
a mídia como atividade em si começa a se
tornar um fenômeno cultural e não mais
um fenômeno de nicho não mais um
fenômeno de uma categoria da sociedade
que faz um trabalho e ganha por conta
disso se tornava algo de uma geração
talvez a gente intuir fazer mídia fazer
um novo jornalismo seja um movimento que
vai definir a nossa geração
do lado pessoal ah eu estava num
conflito muito grande que eu vivia numa
eu é ganhar a minha vida numa mídia
convencional tentando construir uma
mídia diferente alternativa né
mas a decisão ficou muito clara do que
onde deveria seguir no final de 2012
quando a ideia da mídia ninja aparece o
nome ninja aparece uma circunstância
muito peculiar né eu precisava ganhar
grande precisa ganhar dinheiro e queria
ganhar dinheiro vivendo esse mundo o
novo possivelmente não havia muito a
solução após tv havia se consolidado
como um canal de baixíssima audiência
mas de muita a construção de muita
relevância para quem o fazia
mas a minha vontade era explorar o
jornalismo particularmente ea gente
discutia muito a ideia de narrativa o
que significa narrativa nesse sentido a
gente fala muito essa palavra a gente
também pensa muito pouco sobre ela
a gente vive num mundo que é realmente
um mar de informação né agente de algo
que a gente tinha profunda escassez
antes da internet e particularmente
antes das redes sociais para um mundo de
extrema ambulância aonde a informação
pode se tornar inclusive ruído de um
deserto a gente chegou num dilúvio
informacional o que é narrativa na nossa
cabeça a narrativa é como você em cadeia
essa informação como você conta os fatos
e que tipo de tecnologia você vai
construir já que o fato isolado tem
pouca relevância dentro de uma
perspectiva onde as pessoas têm acesso a
infinitas informações novas todo o
momento a gente percebia que mais do que
uma guerra midiática entre veículos de
comunicação era uma guerra de imaginário
de que tipo de sociedade a gente vive do
outro lado do lado da mídia convencional
eu sentia comigo e muito mais do que
comigo porque eu tinha uma missão
interessante pra fazer me sentia muito
otimista e ainda me sinto eu via os meus
colegas numa crise muito mais séria do
que a crise financeira que os grandes
veículos passam gravemente hoje em dia
que é uma crise existencial e qual o
sentido do trabalho né
as pessoas é o jornalista se tornando
cada vez mais cínico e o público cada
vez mais cético né e havia algo novo
para ser feito nesse caminho as pessoas
precisavam entender de alguma forma que
o jornalismo cidadão não é simplesmente
uma palavra não é simplesmente uma
expressão da moda ele significa parte de
ser um cidadão hoje em dia você pelo
menos saber se comportar como um
jornalista o nome ninja aparece
juntamente com uma intenção de ser pop o
suficiente para representar esse
movimento cultural
esse movimento que eu acredito que é de
geração e não um movimento de mercado
simplesmente que é como se tenta
resolver o problema da a mídia a vontade
de ser pop simplesmente ter um nome que
pegasse mais que significa alguma coisa
ninja foi uma sugestão de uma amiga
débora pinho do crédito pra ela só quer
uma coisa tipo ninja feliz de ter feito
cabe às narrativas independentes
o jornalismo ea ação que é o fato do
jornalista não simplesmente ser um
cumpridor de notícias
mas ele realmente interferir no mundo
vendo jornalismo comum antes de mais
nada recuperando a sua função social a
origem dele na verdade que não é ganhar
dinheiro não mais são business não é
vender anúncios para se viabilizar o
jornalismo aparece como uma profissão
política antes de mais nada como algo
essencial pra você
amálgama algo que é é cada vez mais
importante que você estabelecer um
espaço de diálogo público comum que você
como em seguir fomentar o que a internet
permite que a gente chegue lá que é o
consciente coletivo cada vez mais lúcido
e cada vez mais informado a a mídia
ninja aparece com muito poucas
pretensões de se tornar esse fenômeno
que se tornou tão rápido
ninguém podia prever junho mas a gente
sabia que tinha alguma coisa no ar muita
gente entendeu a mídia ninja como algo
que apareceu pra cobrir as manifestações
a mídia já apareceu para tentar fazer
uma outra coisa mas que as manifestações
acabaram representando muito bem essa
outra coisa era tentar convencer o
jornalista que o que está em crise é o
modelo comercial não o jornalismo tentar
pegar essa geração de comunicadores
jovens que nós já nascem em rede que já
nascem se sentindo comunicadores que não
entendem o jornalismo como algo separado
das suas vidas necessariamente e
contaminar um com o outro e talvez o
mais importante seja oferecer para o
público algo que existe uma demanda uma
expectativa muito grande que é uma
quebra narrativa que é uma outra forma
de se produzir informação junho não só
catapultou a gente pra essa fama não
porque a gente é muito grande mas porque
a gente era muito articulado
nacionalmente fruto do trabalho após tv
e particularmente fruto da extrema
capacidade de organização e de
capilaridade do fora do eixo mas também
porque a
eu acho que a gente subestima um pouco
junho como simplesmente um fenômeno
político
eu acho que ele é tanto um fenômeno
político ou mais na verdade um fenômeno
de comunicação
se você fosse para as ruas em junho e e
você pode ir até hoje eu via
literalmente mais placas heh criticando
a rede globo a folha de são paulo do que
o alckmin por exemplo que era
possivelmente maior responsável pela
violência policial que levou tanta gente
para a rua
ah eu acho que a gente provou a nossa
tese naquela hora não porque a gente
virou um fenômeno pop mas porque a gente
tocou num ponto essencial encarar a
mídia encarar a produção ea difusão de
informação e o questionamento do que o
jornalismo é do ponto de vista de
geração do ponto de vista de um
movimento cultural que pode definir não
só a nossa época mas se crucial para a
gente dar conta desse século e aí parece
coisa grandiloqüente falar do século mas
é justamente sobre isso que gostaria de
falar mesmo no final da minha fala que é
é é que a gente não se dá conta ainda
também a gente ainda muito refém de uma
mentalidade forjada no século 20 e no pi
na mentalidade industrial o que a
internet representa não é só uma quebra
de paradigma como é uma quebra de
paradigma tecnológico econômico
comercial ou meramente de comunicação
ela é uma quebra de paradigma da nossa
espécie de verdade pela primeira vez a
gente conseguiu construir uma rede de
comunicação que transforma a gente um
superorganismo e isso acontece
simultaneamente com o maior desafio da
nossa história como espécie realmente é
uma crise planetária é de complexidade
virtualmente infinita em que apenas
soluções coletivas emergentes é
descentralizada smas feitas de maneira
convergente e isso só um sistema de
comunicação perfeitamente integrado no
mundo é capaz de fazer o jornalismo se
torna uma atividade civil fundamental
absolutamente crucial para que a gente
não só engrosse esse caldo mas
pra que ele pra que talvez ele responda
então o que que o jornalismo é de fato o
que é jornalismo
a melhor resposta que eu tenho depois de
desses meses que parece uma vida já é
que a função do jornalismo antes de mais
nada a expansão da consciência a
expansão da consciência pública e se a
gente não expandir a nossa consciência
pública o mais rápido possível e da
maneira mais lúcida bem informada
possível e de maneira não só
independente mas inter independente
a gente vai ter um século do século um
século é muito desejável mas eu sou
absolutamente otimista a a acho que a
gente viveu a infância desse processo
todo e e assim que encerrar minha fala
falando que o poder do juntos pra pra
mim representa exatamente isso
a construção dessa consciência coletiva
e da capacidade que a gente tem não só
de se comunicar mas de criar soluções é
emergentes complexas pra o problema é
que no fundo é de todos nós também
muito obrigado
ainda não